das wahlergebnis hätte mehrere
koalitionen möglich gemacht aber nur
eine ist wirklich zwingend unvermeidbar
alternativlos die ampel die heute
endgültig aus der taufe gehoben wurde
hampel pathos inbegriffen jetzt beginnt
der alltag der es in sich hat krisen
alltag keine flitterwochen
wahrscheinlich gut so die koalition
steht was bringt die ampel jetzt in der
phoenix runde
präsentiert den vertrag das sind die
neuen so genannten haupt verhandler auf
dem weg so gar nicht so feierlichen doch
eher spröden verkündigung papier ist
geduldig
177 seiten die in den nächsten jahren zu
politischem handeln werden sollen
überschrift mehr fortschritt wagen
und damit herzlich willkommen bei uns
meine gäste zunächst hier im studio ist
helene bobrowski sie sind
korrespondentin der parlamentsredaktion
der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung hier
in berlin
kirchner ist bei uns
politikwissenschaftler und psychologe
geschäftsführer des instituts für
kommunikation und gesellschaft in
potsdam und zugeschaltet sind uns bascha
mika journalistin ehemalige
chefredakteurin von taz und frankfurter
rundschau
und schließlich der publizist und
verleger wolfram weimer herr kirchner
wenn sie sich den auftritt die
präsentation des koalitionsvertrags da
angesehen haben heute was sagt das
eigentlich auch schon allein optisch von
dem was da vermittelt worden ist über
das zukünftige ampelbündnis das
interessante war ja dass dort nicht nur
über inhalte gesprochen oder sondern
dass sich wirklich alle parteien spd fdp
und grünen auch über stilfragen geäußert
haben es gab insbesondere so die
szenerie wo robert habeck gesagt hat es
geht eben auch darum dass man mal hinter
das zurück tritt was man immer so
erzählt die anderen wirklich versucht zu
verstehen und daraus etwas neues
entstehen zu lassen oder auch dieses
wirke sehr starkes statement von
christian linder der gesagt hat er wird
ein starker kanzler sein das heißt
nachdem er schon so ein bisschen
durchgedrungen ist dass da nicht alles
wirklich viele freude eierkuchen war und
jetzt war seitens der grünen noch gesagt
das ist nach unserer gehabt gab es heute
den demonstrativen wunsch dort einigkeit
zu signalisieren auch so einen aufbruch
auch wirklich herr vorzunehmen dieser
aufruf sollte auch stilistisch und
kulturellen sein dass ich gerade jetzt
angesprochen habe das immer gleich noch
ein bisschen vertiefen toporowski
irgendwie ist es ja ein sprung nach vorn
wie groß er sein wird das werden wir
sehen aber in sachen klima
digitalisierung verkehrswende
sozialstaat hat sich die ampel ja viel
vorgenommen ja das sind große pläne und
die frage ist halt tatsächlich wie viel
davon möglich ist das hat ja olaf scholz
sehr am anfang ganz am anfang deutlich
gemacht er hat ja nicht sein erstes
statement da ging es ja gar nicht um den
koalitionsvertrag sondern er hat
angefangen mit der korona pandemie und
gesagt die lage ist ernst und das ist
setzt natürlich auch ein gewisser weise
jetzt erst mal den ton für für das was
bevorsteht das ist vollkommen unklar wie
lange uns diese pandemie noch noch
beschäftigen wird wie ernst die lage
möglicherweise noch werden wird und wie
viel spielraum dann eigentlich für
anderes ist ja das ist die hypothek
natürlich mit der diese neue koalition
startet und in der tat die ziele sind
jedenfalls relativ groß würde ich sagen
also jeder jeder partner hätte sich der
bestimmt in seinem bereich noch mehr
vorgestellt man wollte keinen kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner ich glaube auch ist
es gelungen dass jeder in seinem bereich
was erreicht hat
genau und natürlich hätte sich auch
jeder das ist klar wahrscheinlich auch
mehr vorstellen können da kommen wir
sicherlich im einzelnen auch noch lewis
formica
realitätsnähe
machbarkeit das zeichnet einen guten
vertrag aus haben sich die koalitionäre
in einigen bereichen zu viel vorgenommen
beiden es ist ja auch mit widerstand zu
rechnen
selbstverständlich werden sie mit
widerstand rechnen das hat man ja heute
schon gemerkt dass die opposition sich
schon aufgestellt hat also die linken
und die cdu und sehr viel zu kritisieren
hatte an im koalitionsvertrag aber ich
würde es mal umgekehrt sagen
mit diesem koalitionsvertrag mit dieser
ampel ist der staat auch ein ganzes
stück in der wirklichkeit angekommen
also zum beispiel dass die ministerien
paritätisch mit männern und frauen
besetzt werden sollen dass das wahlalter
auf 16 runtergeschraubt werden soll wenn
denn der bundesrat bzw das
verfassungsgericht zustimmt
quatsch wenn es eine verfassungsänderung
geben ja so richtig
in der migration gibt es eine ganze
reihe punkte die eigentlich auch die
nicht nur die flüchtlinge mehr schützen
sondern auch die integration hier im
lande von von menschen vereinfachen es
gibt ein
gleichstellungsstelle zukauf belange von
von frauen in allen bereichen also immer
wenn es ein gesetz geben soll soll das
eben dagegen gecheckt werden und das
sind alles punkte würde ich sagen die
sind in der realität zb auch eine
kindergrundsicherung wo eben
verschiedene leistungen gebündelt werden
das sind alles bereiche
die in der realität so notwendig waren
und die werden jetzt umgesetzt sind ja
vor allem gerechnet politischer ist
natürlich auch von meiner seite
der gesellschaftspolitische nicht also
ich meine wohl wo es eine integration
migration wo man möglicherweise nicht so
schnell zu kompromissen gibt es
ja aber das finde ich ist ist so einfach
denn wenn es zum beispiel auch um
gleichstellung sex geht in bezug auf
frauen
das sind schon hardcore team und wir
schieben ich habe das gar nicht als paar
oder soft themen gemeint sondern dass es
da unter den koalitionären
möglicherweise relativ viel
übereinstimmung gibt herr weimer
das den zukünftigen kanzler hat er als
führungsstarke persönlichkeit bezeichnet
mit innerem geländer das war kein
sozialdemokrat und das war christian
lindner gewesen
das lässt darauf schließen dass das
binnenklima in der sie jetzt
entstehenden koalition ganz gut sein
muss
also ich denke der tanker zwei gute
nachricht die eine ist wir kriegen bald
eine neue jung die ampel steht wirklich
und man hat gemerkt die bemühen sich um
ein persönliches verstehen also sie
haben wirklich eine vertrauens- ebene
aufgebaut und haben miteinander ein
einvernehmen und die einlassung von
christian lindner war auch wirklich
respekt zollen und eine geste um zu
demonstrieren dass man guten willens ist
mir fehlte am tag so ein bisschen der
zauber des neubeginns oder auch ein
stück faszination wenn man sich erinnert
damals als gerhard schröder durch der
fischer angetreten sind und ihren
koalitionspakt resultiert hatten oder
bei großen wänden in der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte davon
war heute gar nichts zu spüren das war
doch eine sachliche romanze wann war
bemüht um sachliche zuneigung aber es
fehlte jede faszination und das kam mir
manchmal so vor mehr wie die
präsentation des vorstands der sparkasse
recklinghausen die jetzt eine
ordentliche bilanz vorlegt aber es war
nicht visionäre aufbruch soll ich jetzt
gerade auch mit sprühte auch gemeint war
wäre ich da mal kurz wenn ich dann mal
kurz dazwischen dazwischen gehen darf
ich finde ihre formulierung
ausgesprochen hübsch mit der sparkasse
aber stellen sie sich vor die hätten
eine große show gemacht und das in
corona zeiten also corona dämpft das
ganze doch auf eine dermaßen art und
weise dass diese dieser aufbruchs wind
der zunächst zu spüren war als es klar
war es geht auf eine ampel zu
kommune hat das alles gehört gemacht gut
ich reserviere jetzt mal dabei versuchen
eine programmatik dass man versucht hat
das im guten einvernehmen
mehr mir fortschritt wagen und die
anlehnung macht dann willy brandt und
bietet dann noch nicht mal ein neues
digital ministerium sondern stattdessen
ein wohnungsbauministerium neu dann ist
das natürlich dann gibt es nun
konkurrenzen in der wahrnehmung und
deswegen ich hätte gedacht die gehen ins
future um die gehen in den ersten
klimaneutralen
solarpark gehen
an den digitalen ort der republik aber
siege sind ihr den westhafen von berlin
gegangen das ist ungefähr das
altmodische was ich mir vorstellen kann
und das wirkte dann so komisch mit
dieser starke rhetorik fortschritt wagen
und dann kam wieder die stimmung auf
noch die programmatik und das ist mir
aufgefallen resümieren jetzt aber auch
abgesehen von dem ort an dem das eine
stadt fahren dass man sich bemüht hat um
gutes einvernehmen man kann aber da war
ja auch über das ziel hinausschießen und
es war ja nicht die einzige haltungsnote
die christian lindner verteilt hat heute
in bezug auf olaf scholz starke
führungspersönlichkeit sondern er hat ja
auch nochmal mit einem mit einer kurzen
bemerkung signalisiert dass ich sowohl
spd wie auch bündnisgrüne bei ihm sehr
gut aufgehoben fühlen können wir schauen
uns diese noten von christian lindner an
mainz und ersetzt haben wir teilweise
stunden gerungen
sozialdemokraten und grüne können jetzt
stolz sein auf das was sie in diesem
koalitionsvertrag hineinverhandelt haben
das waren starke verhandler guten
argumenten ich glaube dass unsere
zukünftigen partner in der
ampelkoalition
in ihren parteien mit besten argumenten
für dieses verhandlungsergebnis werben
können das war so eine art
überlegenheitssieg muss von christian
lindner strotzen vor selbstbewusstsein
manchmal gesagt er gönnerhaft sei das
genießen kann man daraus auch dann
lernen aus dieser äußerung auch auf
einem auftreten wie er sich da gegeben
hat bei dieser präsentation dass er sich
als eigentlich als der gewinner der
koalitionsverhandlungen sieht als ich
bin über diesen auftritt oder die genau
diese szene auch gestolpert ich fand das
fast anmaßend sein auftreten also klang
so als sei im grunde der kanzler der auf
zwei kleine partner den über den kopf
streichelt und sagt das habt ihr
eigentlich ganz gut gemacht erstaunlich
gut hätte ich gar nicht zugetraut es war
ich fand's irritiert und ich habe mich
gefragt eigentlich ist ja christian
lindner taktisch geschickt und im
auftreten sehr sicher ich habe mich
gefragt ob dieses überhaupt diese dieser
erklärung die er auch gegenüber die
vorher schon zitiert wurde die er
gegenüber olaf scholz als dieses lob
ostentative lob für scholz ob dahinter
auch etwas also ob es fast zu
ausdrücklich war und dass das auch ein
bisschen kaschieren soll was ja in
berlin jedenfalls allgemein bekannt ist
dass die stimmung in den arbeitsgruppen
teilweise sehr schlecht war dass viele
fdp-politiker in einigen gruppen
jedenfalls extrem frustriert waren weil
man doch gemerkt hat dass dieser zauber
des aufbruchs der zauber des anfangs als
die ampel sich sich formte in den
sondierungen dass das schnell verflogen
war dass man in der sache doch in vielen
punkten weit auseinander liegt das ist
sehr schwierig ist dass man eine andere
sprache spricht berbalk hat es ja heute
so nett mit diesen sechs und neun jahre
also man guckt von unterschiedlichen
dingen auf dieselbe sache aber am ende
war es wirklich schwierig und dass man
jetzt wieder versucht so eine zäsur zu
schaffen nach der teilweise schlechten
stimmung auf allen seiten jetzt nochmal
mit diesem heutigen tag neuanfang jetzt
geht's richtig los und dass christian
lindner dass auf diese art und weise
deutlich gemacht hat vielleicht muss man
sagen überdeutlich gemacht hat und ein
bisschen über das ziel hinaus geschossen
ist war so mein eindruck dass wir sehr
viel dem motto der designer der seine
schäfchen ins trockene gebracht hat der
hat viel im koalitionsvertrag
untergebracht es gibt ja eigentlich kaum
einen punkt in diesem koalitionsvertrag
der die fdp richtig verärgert hat
also verhandlungs psychologisch war das
was er dort gemacht hat tatsächlich
unklug also wirklich im nachhinein die
verhandlungspartner dafür zu loben dass
sie so viel umgesetzt haben ist
natürlich etwas also warum muss man das
erwähnen ja wenn das einfach klar werden
würde durch den koalitionsvertrag dann
hätte dass er für sich gesprochen hat es
aber nochmal erwähnt und das ist genau
der unterschied den sie gerade
angesprochen haben das was er gegenüber
olaf scholz gesagt hat das klang
wirklich respekt das klang auch das kann
auch wirklich innerlich und das was er
dort gesagt hat ehrlich gesagt ich
glaube dass ich noch ein bisschen seiner
arroganz durchgekommen und das ist
natürlich etwas was dann die anderen
auch durchaus wahrgenommen haben wir
würden auch als nicht still und
trittsicher
da bezeichnen wir das gemacht hat in
dieser situation ist er über das ziel
hinaus geschossen aber es hat deutlich
staatsmännischer aufgetrieben in diesem
wahlkampf als das vorher der fall war
was ja auch dazu beigetragen dass seine
persönlichen werte deutlich besser
wurden aber er war noch mal kurz auf
ihren punkt zurück kommen erstens man
hätte es in der korona situation nicht
so pathetisch machen können und zweitens
wir reden immer noch über olaf scholz
sowie das heißt das ganze sollte
natürlich auch authentisch sein und dort
dann wirklich so ein feuerwerk dann zu
einfach das wäre auch in der tat seltsam
und ich glaube es geht auch gerade darum
ja in so einer situation einfach eine
ernsthaftigkeit mehr solidität aus
schaan und man darf ja auch nicht
vergessen wir reden von programmatisch
sehr unterschiedlichen parteien von
daher finde ich selbst sondern westhafen
durchaus gar nicht so verkehrt wird gut
wir gehen jetzt auch gleich noch über
feuerwerke obwohl die umgebung so spröde
war das da kommen wir gleich auch noch
mal dazu mit einer anderen äußerung
weimar die man muss ja die bündnisgrünen
so ein bisschen bei laune halten in der
ampelkoalition wegen einer doch sehr
anspruchsvollen und kritischen basis
aber die fdp.die liberalen muss man ja
auch so ein bisschen bei laune halten
von spd und grünen seite her weil sie
kommen ja sozusagen von der anderen
seite
sind sozusagen die displays partei in
diesem bündnis hängt das auch ein
bisschen damit zusammen dass oder ist
das der grund dafür dass die fdp da ganz
gut abgeschnitten hat dass man ihr einen
gewissen rabatt einen politischen rabatt
eingeräumt hat
ja man ist sie entgegen gekommen und man
hat die anschrift des koalitionsvertrag
ein gutes stück geld werden lassen ich
glaube nur das was eben diskutiert wurde
auch das verhalten von christian lindner
heute und diese psychologie in dieser
macht architektur die sich abbildet die
ist ziemlich offenbar es ist so dass
robert habeck und christian lindner das
neue machtzentrum dieser neuen regierung
werden das ist nicht mehr das kanzleramt
das ist eine große veränderung für die
politische kultur unseres landes
diese beiden die sind die achse dieser
neuen republik und die definieren die
verstehen sich übrigens auch die haben
einen erstaunlich guten draht auch
persönlich zueinander gefunden und
daneben wirkt der kanzler eher wie eine
technokratische moderierende ruhige
person seine hanseatische bescheidenheit
hilft ihm dabei die brauchte aber auch
denn die macht architektur ist nun
einfach so dass wir noch nie einen
kanzler hatten der eine drei parteien
regierung anführt mit so wenig stimmen
also er selber hat er nur 25 7 bekommen
die beiden anderen sind immer in der
mehrheit und sie können jederzeit in der
legislatur einen neuen kanzler der cdu
wählen das heißt dazu kommt das gerät
charisma defizit von olaf scholz
gefühlt in der öffentlichkeit sind
habeck und linke die beiden stars und
der kanzler ist ein wenig im hintergrund
deswegen haben wir nach vielen jahren
der vertikalen ordnung unserer macht
jetzt eine horizontale und wir haben
diese neue achse und dies heute sichtbar
und das halte ich wenig gemacht
das glaubt
ja naja ich heute auch heimat wirklich
deutlich widersprechen ich glaube dass
es stimmt dass in der öffentlichkeit
diese achse habeck lindner ist ja sehr
sehr sehr deutlich nach nach außen trägt
und das ja von dieser ganzen citrus
koalition also gelb grün am anfang viel
gesprochen wurde ich glaube du dass das
tatsächlich wirklich nur der allererste
blick ist und dass man dabei olaf scholz
und seine machtposition tatsächlich
deutlich unterschätzt olaf scholz hat
während der ganzen koalitions und auch
sondierungsverhandlungen schon dabei
zugeschaut wie sich fdp und grüne
ineinander verkeilt hatten wieder um das
finanzministerium gestritten haben wie
die um lauter punkte
gerungen hatten und olaf scholz
sozusagen dazwischen und hat so getan
als sei er der moderator zwischen zwei
kindern und in wahrheit sitzt er am
langen hebel der macht und in wahrheit
hat er auch das habe ich noch gehört auf
den letzten metern noch sehr viel im
koalitionsvertrag geändert viele dinge
auch noch mal dazu gebracht dass sie
komplett umformuliert wurden usw olaf
scholz wirkt nicht durch eine laute
stimme und er wirkt auch nicht durch
einen ein sozusagen entschieden das
auftreten aber er wirkt sehr entschieden
im hintergrund und ich glaube jeder das
können auch hamburger berichten jeder
der schon mal mit ihm verhandelt hat der
weiß genau dass man sich sehr sehr warm
anziehen muss und dass er sich bestimmt
von habeck und linden nicht die show
stehlen wollen die bündnisgrünen glaube
ich ja auch so viel festlegen im
koalitionsvertrag mit diesen erfahrungen
haben bascha mika
ich möchte dass nur unterstützt nur noch
einen weiteren aspekt hinzufügen olaf
scholz wurde ja schon während des
wahlkampfs und das hat seinen erfolg
ausgemacht als der wahre nachfolger
merkels
bezeichnet und von der von der
bevölkerung und vom volk so gesehen das
hat ihn nicht nur dorthin gebracht wo er
jetzt ist nämlich kurz vor dem
kanzleramt sondern auch die art also
diese dieses moderierende zumindest nach
außen hin eher zurückgenommen das hat
ihm bisher immer noch die größten
sympathiewerte verschafft alle parteien
haben vor allem in den letzten wochen
seit corona wieder zur katastrophe
geworden ist enorm an zustimmung
verloren enorm die spd hat am wenigsten
verloren die grün einigermaßen schlimm
die fdp am aller deutlichsten und das
heißt wenn jemand vertraut in der
bevölkerung in dieser situation etwas zu
machen und das vertrauen ist im moment
nicht besonders groß in die neue und
künftige regierung dann in die spd und
sehr viel weniger in die beiden anders
als bei corona das heißt wir gerade in
der prokura pandemie ist das auch für
olaf scholz etwas womit er jetzt
sozusagen wieder mehr in den vordergrund
treten kann gerade weil die fdp stark
zurückrudern muss für das was sie jetzt
angekündigt hat und das jetzt
möglicherweise auch in den nächsten
wochen noch beschlossen wird ja er muss
also wir reden ja auch immer noch über
denjenigen die jetzt immer noch der
stellvertretende der stadträte kanzler
ist also das hätte ja schon früher an
der stelle was kommen was nicht teile
das dass er sehr klug agiert hat indem
er sich erstmal zurück gehalten hat und
im hintergrund doch wirklich viel
koordiniert hat aber gerade in der
korona partie hätte das deutlich früher
kommen sollen auch entschieden da kommen
sollen aber ich würde mal ganz gut ihre
beiden positionen nehmen ich teile das
ist schon das ist einfach ein
ausstrahlung gefälle auch ein charisma
gefälle gibt zwischen eben scholz auf
einen haben auf der anderen seite aber
das ding ist die sind nicht nur eine
achse her weil man dadurch ihnen
widersprechen die sind ja auch rivalen
und zwar aus folgendem grund lindner ist
finanzminister hat damit eine funktion
habeck wirtschaft und klimaschutz
wahrscheinlich so wie das jetzt hören
und in dem moment wo es schon das starke
rhetorische bekenntnis gibt zum 5 grad
ziel indem man wo man schon in die
präambel wirklich jetzt alle oberstes
ziel schreiben klimaschutz wird er
natürlich versuchen faktisch so eine art
indirekte videofunktion außen das heißt
die beiden obwohl sich gut verstehen
richtig werden trotzdem rivalen seien in
der frage wer wie stark auch aus statt
und hat sich politik macht lassen sie
bei uns ganz kurz bevor er zur robert
herbekommen weimar auf den inhalt gucken
auf einen aspekt klimaschutz der steht
ja ganz im vordergrund da ist ja jetzt
geplant 2030 schon keine kohle
verstromung mehr in dem gleichen jahr
soll jetzt 80 prozent strom aus
regenerativer energie geben 15 millionen
autos e auto sollen auf deutschen
straßen rollen alles noch am ende des
laufenden jahrzehnts
ist das ist das realistisch ist das aber
etwas was die die ampel koalition auch
gebraucht hat um zu sagen wir verändern
etwas dass ich sie jetzt der große wurf
wir wollen irgendetwas gestalten
zunächst mal ist es ambitioniert und es
ist nachvollziehbar aus der programmatik
insbesondere der grünen es ist und
deswegen konnte so viel kritik von
grünen ngo natürlich häufig in dem
koalitionsvertrag nur apella tief oder
wir wollen dieses ziel erreichen oder
wir streben an
das ist natürlich fielen aus der szene
zu wenig ich finde aber da machen sie
einen klaren punkt auch einen
ordnungspolitischen punkt mit klaren
ziel marken und da und man kann ihn
abnehmen das ja auch alles politische in
die wege leiten wollen das zu erreichen
sagt die ministerin ihren zufrieden sein
er in diesen kern wird der kern des
programmatischen heißt ja fortschritt
und da hätte ich erwartet dass wir ein
klima ministerium bekommen stattdessen
haben wir ein irgendwie um klima
kompetenzen aufgerüstetes
wirtschaftsministerium und daneben noch
ein umweltministerium warum eigentlich
ich hätte erwartet dass wir endlich
einen digitalisierung zu ministerium
bekommen das motto lautet mehr
fortschritt wagen stattdessen kriegen
wir das nicht sondern wir kriegen ein
wohnungsbauministerium was wir in den
50er jahren gebraucht hätten aber heute
nicht so unbedingt
gut wir haben also die den
koalitionsvertrag wir haben das
auftreten der chor zu nähren die die
jetzt demnächst die bundesregierung
bilden die regel wesentlichen positionen
die wichtigsten ministerien der
der bundesgeschäftsführer der
bündnisgrünen michael kellner hat gesagt
es sei in manchen gesprächen brutal
anstrengend gewesen das hat aber
offensichtlich sein parteichef anders
empfunden robert habeck denn der hat die
erfahrung gemacht dass es in manchen
dieser gespräche geradezu therapeutisch
zugegangen ist und wir wollen uns diese
äußerung von robert habeck heute
nachmittag jetzt noch mal ansehen die
entscheidenden momente bei diesen
verhandlungen war machen immer dann wenn
man voneinander gelernt hat nachdem man
sich seine programmpunkte vorgetragen
hat und gesagt hat wie konnte so doof
sein das nicht zu verstehen das habt ihr
schon der 20 jahren gehört hört endlich
mal zu und die lautstärke wurde immer
größerer gab es manchmal momente wo es
gekippt ist und man den hintergrund der
argumentation verstanden hat und dann
wurden neue lösungen möglich und so löst
sich vielleicht auch in dieser ampel ein
was wir für die gesellschaft beschreiben
gegensätze können überwunden werden
durch eine lernende politik einen lernen
des deutschland ja frau bobrowski das
war ein crashkurs in politischer
empathie gewesen hat da robert habeck
auch etwas zu dick aufgetragen
ich würde sagen es ein typischer harbeck
wenn er gut drauf ist also war ich war
verstolpert dass ich ja auch irgendwie
gut hingekriegt oder hat ja die sind
immer diesen überbau der nicht nur sich
sozusagen auf das tägliche auf die
tagespolitik und die ganz konkreten
vorhaben beschränkt sondern er bekommt
es ja immerhin so negativ darum zu bauen
was er eigentlich will und das ist ja
auch machte er sein talent auch aus was
ich für die grünen interessant finde ist
dass sie im grunde sie haben jetzt also
von den fünf ministerien von den fünf
häusern die wir sollten sie sie
übersetzen chris
kulturstaatsminister haben sie drei die
eigentlich klassisch öko häuser sind
grün also umweltwirtschaft klima und
landwirtschaft und ernährung das sind es
ist klassisches grünes gelände sozusagen
und dann haben sie noch familie und
auswärtiges amt und das auswärtige amt
ist für die grünen auch nichts neues das
hatten sie schon 1998 damals war es
natürlich was ganz besonderes sondern
auch eine zumutung für die partei heute
nicht mehr so und es gab ja verschiedene
andere häuser die im gespräch waren für
die grünen ein führender werfer gewesen
ein amt oder einen ministerium
anzustreben mit dem die grünen von haus
aus fremd ging ja ja ich meine der der
anspruch der grünen und der anspruch den
robert habeck und annalena baerbock
immer formuliert haben war ja der aus
griff in andere teile der bevölkerung
ein breiteres aufstellen der politische
vollsortimenter also nicht in der öko
ecke bleiben sondern ein breites angebot
genau sie haben wir das war ja schon im
wahlkampf zu sehen als es nicht gut lief
für die grünen dass sie sich immer mehr
wieder ihrer grünen klientel
zugewandt hatten und das haben sie jetzt
fortgesetzt und all die ideen diesmal
gab es wäre auch sicherlich für die
grünen eine zumutung das
innenministerium zu nehmen aber
überhaupt dieser dieser anderen themen
mal an zu denken das haben sie jetzt
nicht getan und vielleicht kann man das
auch mit 14,8 prozent nicht dass wir
vielleicht eine andere situation gewesen
hätten sie tatsächlich 20 oder mehr
bekommen aber es ist es schon in dieser
frage eine sage ich meine bescheidenheit
und und auch eine thematische begrenzung
die sie davon also kirchner die die
bundesregierung als eine positive stand
eine selbsterfahrungsgruppe wenn man das
jetzt gerade gehört hat das kann ja
eigentlich nur ein böses erwachen geben
wenn es den ersten großen knall gibt bei
einer krise die ja auch der
ampelkoalition
mutmaßlich nicht erspart bleibt das hat
robert haider gemacht sein typisches
meter ja also hat er ganz geschichte so
eine übergeordnete erzählung zu geben
die methode die er beschreibt ist die
sokratische bioethik ja also ich frage
immer ganz intensiv nach hinterfrage
mich selbst um dance neuen lösung zu
kommen er hat gesagt diese wenigen
momente das heißt dass wird es ab und zu
geben war eher eine frage des stils aber
er würde ganz kurz auf das angebot
oscars sie gesagt haben das
außenministerium zu nehmen ja klar
hatten die grünen das schon mal das
jetzt aber eine sehr heikle situation
mit diversen krisen die man hat und das
darf man nicht vergessen die grünen
mussten in vielen politikfeldern
einstecken aber nicht in der
außenpolitik es soll die föderale
europäische republik gehen ist dort
transnationale listen geben und es soll
relativ stark menschenrechts geleitete
außenpolitik darf ich kurz an die ganzen
prozentpunkt nach der schwierigkeit ist
die dadurch dass die grünen da aber
einen sehr hohen anspruch haben können
sie daran auch durchaus also es kann
sehr schwierig denn das uns kurz nur
ergänzen also kein haus ist so wenig von
parteipolitik geprägt wie das auswärtige
amt also es ist so sehr von deutscher
staatsraison
durchtränkt und es ändert sich so wenig
in dem haus abhängig davon wer die
führung stellt das man da programmatisch
kaum was bewegen kann und all diese
ziele gerade in der europäischen politik
die sie beschreiben mit blick auf die eu
das sind natürlich programmatisch
vorhaben der grünen die sie aber wo sie
lediglich in der eu diese bitte diesen
antrag stellen können aber wo natürlich
man 27 länder braucht die mitziehen und
die gibt es nicht das heißt man kann das
formulieren und das klingt auch gut aber
das ist natürlich eine utopie die
braucht es vielleicht auch aber
in der außenpolitik weil die position
russlands gegenüber zwischen spd und
bündnisgrünen hier sehr weit auseinander
liegt ich würde gerne nochmal bascha
mika zu robert habeck zurückkehren
wolfram weimer hat vorhin gesagt er sei
möglicherweise gemeinsam mit christian
lindner das neue machtzentrum in der
koalition als was wenn man sich jetzt
diese note oder noch einmal ansieht als
was versteht er sich eigentlich in
dieser koalition wenn er auch teil eines
machtzentrums ist der da möglicherweise
auch den ton angeben kann in der neuen
koalition
also ich glaube das ist eine mischung
die begriffe sind auch schon gefallen
aus derjenige der den überbau liefert
das heißt er die erzählung liefert und
natürlich war das ein bisschen
wortgeklingel nach dem motto lernende
politik auf der anderen seite fand ich
es auch gar nicht schlecht weil es
knüpfte an die erfahrungen seit der
pandemie zeit dass sich politische
ansagen ständig verändert haben dass die
wissenschaft immer nachbessern bessern
musste und für alle die das sozusagen
leibhaftig erlebt haben
klang das für mich erst mal wie eine
politik die eben tatsächlich etwas dazu
gelernt hat dass sie bereit ist auch
eigene fehler einzugestehen
auch nachzubessern wenn es denn nötig
ist also insoweit ist er der erzähler
dieser großen koalition
entschuldigung dieser dieser ampel
koalition und und dadurch
ist es natürlich auch ein stück macht
weil wir wissen dass uns zum beispiel
gerade in der großen koalition immer die
erzählung fehlte da war mir diese heute
ein stück mitzuliefern
finde ich finde ich gar nicht gar nicht
ungeschickt zum anderen ist robert
habeck natürlich genauso wie annalena
baerbock diejenigen die für die
klimapolitik der künftigen regierung ein
stehen werden und das ist natürlich der
massen schwierig sie haben versprochen
wir kommen auf den 15 grad
aber wir wissen genau an wie vielen
sachen dass das hemmt sie reden vom
kohleausstieg
idealerweise
2030 das heißt das kann sich alles
ändern und das kann sich mit der kohle
noch weiter draußen mit dem vorbehalt
ist ja dass schichten auch dass die
energiemenge zur verfügung steht das
muss ich ja auch soziale aspekte dabei
noch zu lösen wolfram weimer wenn sie ja
ich nehme es nochmal das auch was ich
wollte mal was ich vorhin gesagt haben
mit dem machtzentrum den neuen kabeg und
christian lindner
dieses dieser begriff den christian
lindner wir gerade schon von narrativen
gesprochen da hat er heute mehrfach
benutzte regierung der mitte sei dass
jetzt die ampelkoalition das hat nur er
benutzt aber zeichnet das relativ
deutlich dass nach was in dieser achse
lindner habig zu erwarten ist für die
regierungsarbeit
beide dringend zur mitte und wollen sich
auch über die mitte definieren weil
beide natürlich noch höhere ambitionen
haben wenn wir mal an die nächste
bundestagswahl denken mir geht es wie
becker ich fand auch die tonalität heute
sehr angenehm das war nicht nur eine des
einvernehmens sondern eben auch im
pommerschen sinne eine falsifizieren de
sind menschen des irrtums und tasten uns
voran es ist aber etwas anderes noch
offenbar geworden weil so eine
präsentation ist ja auch immer ein
menuett tanzen des protokolls und es ist
schon aufgefallen dass nach olaf scholz
als erstes habe ich reden durfte und
dann christian lindner und dann wollte
schon fressen das wort ergreifen wurde
aber unterbrochen nein nein wir müssen
doch annalena baerbock noch irgendetwas
sagen lassen das heißt die entmachtung
die von annalena baerbock innerhalb der
grünen partei die wurde heute schon sehr
deutlich gemacht das heißt habeck hat
das erste wort im wahrsten sinne des
wortes und das hat er auch demonstriert
übrigens auch damit da komme ich zu
meiner achsen these zurück das ist
lindner und habe heute abend zusammen
bei was nun herr lindner airbag im zdf
waren und eben dieses gemeinsam erklärt
und da war nicht mehr annalena baerbock
oder einer alleine sondern diese beiden
demonstrieren diese achse auch richtig
offensiv
kirche also was er gesagt hat war anna
lena ist jetzt dran sonnig so anna lena
soll jetzt das machen aber er wird
erfasst anderes hinaus nämlich die frage
wie kann man das insgesamt ein die ganze
geschichte und diese ganze
koalitionsvertrag das was jetzt im kern
dabei rauskommt erinnert mich an das was
andreas ragwitz an der soziologisch aus
berlin gesagt hat nämlich eingebetteter
liberalismus dass man sagt auf der einen
seite haben wir schon so bestimmte
vorgaben der mindestlohn 12 euro ein
relativ stabiles rentensystem 48 prozent
also spd steht für dieses eingebettete
und auf der anderen seite das hat er
auch sehr klar gesagt haben wir diesen
links liberalismus für den die grünen
stehen und er so wirklich den
wirtschaftsliberalismus der fdp und das
ganze mündet dann ins tor und das haben
sie ganz am anfang gesagt in vielen
gesellschaftspolitischen dingen dass man
einerseits sagt okay wir wollen im
bereich der migration nach stellen wir
wollen das wahlalter senken wir wollen
mehr sexuelle selbstbestimmung haben das
heißt in vielen auf wenige kontroversen
gibt richtig aber wo und das ist ja der
große unterschied wo jetzt dinge möglich
sind die mit der union vorher nicht
möglich gewesen wären und deswegen das
wird heute ganz viel darüber gesprochen
wer so diese wahl gewonnen hat er finde
die demokratie ist heute auch
tatsächlich ein sieger denn es ist
deutlich geworden eine andere koalition
als wir sie haben mit zwei neuen
parteien in der regierung sorgt in
einigen fällen tatsächlich auf eine
andere politik das heißt wahlen haben
auch einen effekt und finde das auch
eine botschaft des heutigen tages es gut
es hat also wir haben ja die beiden
ausschnitte gezeigt so was wie das
flechten von dort gelangten heute
gegeben bei dieser präsentation
christian lindner und robert habeck
einer wollte aber auf jeden fall auf dem
boden bleiben keine überraschung olaf
scholz
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung
wir wollen uns etwas zutrauen beim
klimaschutz beim umbau unserer industrie
bei der modernisierung des landes bei
der stärkung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts
wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen also
er möchte die große wirkung haben nicht
den kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner das ist
sicherlich selbstverständlich man will
sich etwas zutrauen man will etwas wagen
eigentlich fast zurückgenommen auch in
der wortwahl und olaf scholz vielleicht
auch dass die bäume der ampel koalition
möglicherweise doch nicht in den himmel
wachsen so wie sie vielleicht robert
habeck und christian lindner in den
himmel wachsen sehen lassen wollen
jedenfalls das so tun als würden sie das
glauben olaf scholz ist natürlich sehr
also der mann irgendwie der tat nicht
des großen wortes und der hat natürlich
erst jetzt lange genug dabei um zu
wissen dass das alles nicht so einfach
ist also keiner hat ja die letzten vier
jahre so eng an der seite der kanzlerin
die ganzen geschicke des landes
irgendwie mitbestimmt saß bei jeder
wichtigen runde mit am tisch weiß was
geht und was nicht geht insofern ist das
ja auch ausdruck irgendwie sozusagen
sein es wie soll man sagen realismus ja
also er ist sicherlich kein mann der
großen vision und stimmt da in dieser
hinsicht natürlich mit seiner
vorgängerin überein und übrigens das ist
ja was was in deutschland sehr gut
ankommt ja deutsche haben ja ein großes
misstrauen gegenüber riesen visionären
die ihnen sonst was versprechen sondern
sozusagen besser ist ja dieses menschen
denen die nicht so vielversprechend den
mann aber dann abnimmt was sie falsch
was sie was sie vielleicht schon
versprechen und das scheint ja bei olaf
scholz das ist ja teil seines
erfolgsrezepts gut wir müssen ja immer
wieder darauf hinweisen kirchner das ist
der nächste bundeskanzlerin jetzt
zunächst davon lindner und habe
gesprochen die nach außen hin
mehr profil zeigen sich mehr in den
vordergrund spielen olaf scholz das ist
knallhartes politisches graubrot fast
immer in der gleichen tonalität von ihm
stammt aber auch der satz wer bei mir
führung bestellt bekommt führung das
würde noch brauchen können bei dieser
mannschaft ihr da hinter sich hat wie
passt das eigentlich zusammen sein
auftreten und ein machtanspruch und auch
ein führungsanspruch und offensichtlich
hat er ja seid ihr das wissen als
bürgermeister von hamburg da durchaus ja
auch erfolge gehabt wir haben 16 jahre
lang gesehen dass es nicht die beste
rhetorik oder eine folge rhetorik
braucht um dann tatsächlich wirklich
effektiv zu führen und die fäden auch
ganz kleine hand zu behalten und wir
dürfen auch zwei dinger nicht vergessen
also den menschen wachsen dafür
gewöhnlich mit ihren aufgaben und mit
dem amt und es wird auch so eine
situation geben ich denke hatte auch
durchaus einiges an negativen feedback
bekommen was die rede im bundestag
dagegen zu krone also ich denke er wird
selber dort auch noch mal nachsteuern
denn das möchte dann der schon dazusagen
solche botschaften heute vom zettel
abzulesen so also das geht tatsächlich
in so einer situation nicht das sollte
tatsächlich frei geschehen aber ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass er da noch mal
nachsteuern wird und olaf scholz wird
der schlauch denken das rückspiel oder
wirklich die bilanz die wird dass 2025
gezogen und er ist aber auch jemand der
eben sagt also er möchte eben eher an
den taten als an den worten gemessen
werden deswegen wird er glaube ist ein
stil auch grundsätzlich nicht verändern
aber die leute wissen das doch auch weil
wer olaf scholz gehört wusste genau dass
er eben genau diesen politikertypus
bekommen er war über diesen befund von
einig dass
dieser befund den sie jetzt den sie
vorhin am anfang der sendung zitiert
haben denn ich jetzt zum dritten mal
hier wiederholen nämlich das
machtzentrum das sind habeck und das
sind lindner kann das denn jemand wie
olaf scholz auf sich auf sich sitzen
lassen
ich glaube er ist klug genug und da hat
er wirklich in eine begabung eine
machtpolitische sich angela merkel an
abgeschaut
die beiden wirken zu lassen er braucht
nicht die bühne ganz vorne ich glaube
bei ihm ist eine ganz andere sache im
moment im vordergrund nämlich seine
eigene partei wer heute genau
hingeschaut hat er hat gemerkt er hat
ein bisschen sorge das sind seine
eigenen partei die dinge jetzt auch so
durchgehen und er glatt gewählt wird und
dass alles so stabil bleibt wie es jetzt
seit einem jahr innerhalb der spd ja
ganz ungewohnt aber stabil ist deswegen
benennt ja die spd auch nicht jetzt
schon anders als die fdp ihren namen für
die ministerposten das wäre doch
eigentlich naheliegend dass das heute
auch verkündet worden wäre
gesundheitsminister wird karl lauterbach
oder eben nicht sondern das tut er ganz
bewusst nicht er will erst die
entscheidung das ja zum vertrag haben er
will erst machtpolitisch alles absichern
weil er seine eigene partei kennt und
ich glaube er hat viel weniger sorge vor
lindner und habeck sondern vor den
eigenen truppen in seiner eigenen partei
bascha mika wird er denn wird olaf
scholz die spd da wirklich hinter sich
dauerhaft schaden können dass er sich
auf sie auch verlassen kann er wäre ja
nicht der erste sozialdemokratische
bundeskanzler der mit der eigenen partei
ziemliche schwierigkeiten hat
ja aber die spd hat ja auch sehr viel
gelernt und man darf nicht vergessen
erfolg macht süchtig und manchmal lernen
sogar parteien was den erfolg verschafft
und in diesem fall zumal man es gesehen
hat wie sehr sich die cdu/csu gestartet
hat durch die querelen innerhalb der
partei bei der spd was ganz anders das
hat ihren erfolg ausgemacht das haben
sie immer betont auch nach der wahl sie
wissen also ganz genau wie es gelaufen
ist und es wäre sozusagen sträflich wenn
diese form von geschlossenheit was ja
nicht bedeutet dass man nicht
innerparteilich diskutiert völlig
aufgebrochen würde aber genauso wie die
grünen und da gebe ich wolfram weimer
völlig recht genauso wie die grünen muss
scholz tatsächlich auch flügelkämpfe
fürchten in der partei
auf der anderen seite saskia esken die
ja sozusagen als besonders linke spd
lerin gilt war die ganze zeit
eingebunden in die koalitionsgespräche
und sie hat sich auch wenn sie nur als
letzte reden durfte trotzdem sehr
euphorisch
geäußert also vielleicht kriegt die spd
das hin ihre innerparteilichen kämpfe so
auszutragen dass es nicht auf schädigend
nach außen wirkt bei den grünen wie
gesagt ist das selbe problem
ergänzen kommt ja noch hinzu dass das es
ja bei den anders als bei der und bei
der cdu sich bei der spd bewährt hat
kanzlerschaft und parteivorsitz nicht in
einer hand zu lassen sondern das
auszubalancieren und jetzt hat er ja mit
lars klingbeil und saskia esken zwei
parteivorsitzenden mit lars klingbeil
kommt persönlich sehr gut klar er hat
auch ein sehr engen draht zu kevin
kühnert der ja sozusagen als der rebell
gilt aber ein mittlerweile ja auch gar
nicht mehr ist saskia esken ist die
kontinuität sozusagen der damaligen
linken revolte in der partei also das
ist schon alles von der ausstellung so
dass das die partei jedenfalls erstmal
befriedet machtposition sorgt auch immer
für inneren frieden erfolg das stimmt
ich wollte noch einmal weil sie es nur
weil sie dreimal wiederholt wir haben
sagen dass ich wirklich auch nicht der
meinung bin und ich glaube frau mika
auch nicht dass das mit der macht achse
habe lindner so stimmt ich habe die
frage angelegt ob es
wirklich also das kann man so
argumentiert ich glaube nur dass es auch
wirklich sehr gute gründe gibt das
anders zu sehen gab auch gute gründe
dass wir zuerst mal über lindner und
habe hier gesprochen haben auch auf der
o töne die wir da heute präsentiert
bekommen haben
komiker ja aber ich ich ich glaube an
einem an einem punkt würde ich mal
versuchen das ganze zusammen zu bringen
also für alle diejenigen die tatsächlich
ein ausbruch erwarten die
fortschritt erwarten sowie das programm
das heute vorgestellt wurde
überschrieben war für die stehen
natürlich lindner auf der einen seite
und harbeck auf der anderen seite
tatsächlich als das machtzentrum
aber wenn man die gesamtbevölkerung
ansieht dann glaub ich sieht es ganz
anders aus und da glaube ich wird olaf
scholz schon seine punkte machen herr
kirchner also wenn wir uns mal kurz das
ganze anschauen mehr fortschritt wagen
alle drei parteien können sich auf
fortschritt einigen und natürlich hat
das eine referenz an die sozial liberale
koalition aber es ist natürlich schon
interessant zu sagen okay freiheit
gerechtigkeit nachhaltigkeit und ich
würde ihnen auch zustimmen gerade dafür
dass die fdp von den wählerstimmen her
die schwächste partei innerhalb dieser
koalition hat sie proportional mehr
durchgesetzt hat vor allem der dinge
verhindert dinge die sie nicht haben
wollte höhere spitzensteuersatz
bürgerversicherung et cetera und das
wird jetzt in der tat für die grünen
nicht ganz ohne denn einerseits das muss
jetzt durch eine urabstimmung die ganze
geschichte sofort ist es ja die
innerparteiliche basisdemokratie da
stark ausgeprägt und dadurch dass er zum
beispiel steht idealerweise bis 2030 und
dadurch das ja auch gesagt für die
investitionen sollen sich im rahmen der
schuldenbremse so halbwegs bald wieder
bewegen klar hat dieser
koalitionsvertrag auf der ebene der
politik dessen was man möchte ein klares
bekenntnis zum klimaschutz aber ob und
wie das jetzt im detail umgesetzt wird
kann mir vorstellen dass da auch noch
kritische stimmen geben wir bleibt nur
noch eine minute er weimar vielleicht
noch eine frage noch eine frage dazu die
die fdp auch die grünen sagen ja immer
wir wollen mit dieser koalition die
nächsten wahlen auch noch gewinnen also
nicht nur jetzt für vier jahre sondern
auch noch länger haben sie da heute
einen ersten schritt dazu gemacht
also ich glaube ja das einverständnis
auch das emotionale der handelnden
figuren das ist wirklich nicht gespielt
es ist da auch das bemühen das zu halten
insofern haben sie auf der abitur allen
ebene einen guten start hingelegt also
dabei jetzt als schlusswort gewesen ich
bedanke mich bei helene bobrowski bei
models kirchner bascha mika und bei
wolfram weimer live zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde
deutschland in der vierten welle helfen
nur impfpflicht und lockdown das ist ja
auch ein wichtiges thema das jetzt
gleich die ampel koalition möglichst
schnell bewältigen sollen jetzt folgt
für dix der tag mit thomas bade der sie
mit weiteren reaktionen zum
koalitionsvertrag versorgt hatten sie
bei uns
[Musik]